Jada Smith has revealed to the Today's
Show that she and will have been
separated for 7 years why did the
relationship
fracture oh why it fractured that that's
a lot of things and I think by the time
we got to 2016 we were just exhausted
with trying I think we were both kind of
still stuck in our fantasy of what we
thought the other person should be Jada
says she considered a legal divorce but
could never go through with it I made a
promise that there will never be a
reason for us to get a divorce we will
work through whatever and I just haven't
been able to break that promise that's
good I know everyone's going to attack
Jada Smith because she seems just
absolutely awful in most ways but I tell
you that is a really redeeming statement
that she just made